звідси stay down
do в спарі його п'яний
фома президент офіс контроль і вас
допитати його співав putin in this once and
fine until this once and mountain by
building a more on me feel like a me in
ukraine
через content and
given a big wound up as для Петра
порошенка
[оплески]
де
шеннона і на президента за нотаріатом
з кров'ю про ішан writer музею
сховалися під літерою повзайте біспінга
maybach дві чуми нашої
лівою кулю європейської народної партії
дику
всі оплески діагнозу сексу дике за
запру слона за такі харчування поні руслан
і я хотів би почату
у вічності президентові
європейської народної партії по навію
дональду тушку за його пробили
призначення заслуга you're the rat європи
більше товару іншу
то за рік
я кевін за вишивку з колишнім літром
ношу та партія європейської народна
партія він на і склад жебрак годинник та 2
завищується баченим промоутером наших
цінностей та принцип
таку активну форму у вів
порядок дані нашої про ти плиткові
сім'ї
успіхи вам дональд та успіхи у вас
овочів подалі політичні кар'єрі це
все ваною красиво
вашому на ступні до
[оплески]
дональд і ми просто йому пальці страшно за
вашу мої будні кар'єрою дусі трузі
вже за раз 97 днів в Україні в.д.
масштабну провину за своє виживання проти
путінського режиму проти я клинка ж
другові б і найсильніша армія у свиті і
я намагаюся ще ми українці
за 2014 року коли я б у горлі
командувачів український твій син створив
цю армію я козу полив і ми столи для
вина стало жахливо криво віші таємниця жертв
та шиї на європейському континенті після
висновки іншої колірної провини і поки що
ми говоримо від десятки та десятки тисяч
українських героїв стримані агрос і поза
орди російських віз якось з них
нормандців на донбасі
на пі поза Україною з мільйона мирних
громадян україни шукають укрити овець
авіаударів то крилатих ракет по всі раку
і не nemo і жадібно поспішно місце у
україні путінські режимі правда і
завоювати наші землі ліквіду ват
українську державність естер ти
українську націю
українську ідентичність старт та скати
почет з історією листя і тих хто
виводити про companies айпад вас до нас
ожив його знає і компроміс цьому зараз
вигляд чорний білий путін хоче б ти
всіх ми просто хочемо у вичавлені
Путін може хоче значить і наш кошик
а ми хочемо може
ще тисяч уроки бути свої вкрай і заряд
вид може побачити справжній телекомпанії
путіна в масових похованнях у бучі
випили в маріуполі в рубіжному
тростинці
президент з осі контролю in було б шо
хто висунув навчання хто побачив тир 2
чиїхось зрозумівши що це таке і цінні
голлівудському світлі ціна багата на йорж
у книжках української історії
співачка графа тріска незаконно референдум
який а правда вище і вона ксу вати ще
більше території на користь російської
фриці українські території
українською а не за лижниця може бути
предметом умовляннями україни це їжі
на часті на його плиткового плану нового
свиту європейського порядку та
і путіна завищується вигляд буду вані педро
дженнер і донську спілку when my я про
гвинтом стабільного вірус за них у простих
відібрали не то рос поттер срср там ще
там ще ріднянський союз розпався тому
вина шатрова цін наша спина вина там
ще в сиднє в поршень там ще в лютому
win-win
спочатку взагалі ціною національні
батальйони ми бабура мийся за українською
інформаційно червоні за місяць вже
сказав він бореться з на ту і ти буде
nevian сказав шо вин бореться тут їм ви
вільним сильним святим
україна прикро збагатив лідерів і я хочу
висоти кухар ще президент маццола я кай
я
магія
метеликів на шпильці об'єкт на україну та
сьогодні ми мої мій зуб їм цієї
російських тур на мене в Україну та
вивезти російських росіян з нашої
території і видно ви ти територіальну
цілісність України включає донбас і
крим
не які вимкнути у
сун цієї будете подалі potency не
загрос і збоку в Росії для зеленого
світла шляхом послаблення російської
економіки
за зрозуміла і там і травень моди pu не
захоплює Російську федерацію для
того легше ми хочемо і справді міг
вільно їх безтурботного квітами моєму д
путіні за ват і Європу with
with a true north путінської демократії та
парник батьківщини ми травня мій запам'ятайте їх та
ми мая моди путін 2 ти святий за галон
то ви ще прям ах ти побаченому
потрібно ступні
більше ваш кого вас броня для України
на лінії фронту
ланцюга зміні кольору явити рахунок sweet
адже закласти тисяч активних виношувати
дві тисячі танків вид тисяч ракетних
установок та we 3000 про тип вітрини
хабарівних систем нам необхідних або
коптери ми точно потребуємо у
про типу кручена note
pro ти морську паркан оборону
нам потрібно берша санкцій наорі в ній з
тау всім а світло не більше санкції ще
дня доку та путін не відразу mia heaven травня
5 5 закраїни і я витаю вчорашній
політичне рішення європейської ради
про
за ти за їхній син і за їхній сильний голос
ще пам'ятають найму жив і ось хвороба юшку і
вся україна процес знаємо і
провід не шастав пакету санкцій
точно в ключ включаючи че ощадбанк включаючи
че свіфт і включаєте нафту
включають багату ним своїх приймає
cc коло і керуємо на премію червоною три
байта і дали шляхом супроводу
повного на авто гмбх загашений і
правильне рішення закривати ці санкції
проти так дзвонова патріархат російської
православної церкви крила яскравою благослою
ви в бути а українці фц і сам знайду я
прошу і чого про сама усі ми
не дурні європейці, оскільки
з сам і крив хтось її близьким соратником
путіна та
поверхня з коми терміново відомому в
Україні так я кручена санкції проти і
адже дужок поганих за масами вислати
було два не це звучання про те люди
насті україни включаючи че бучу та в пік
маріуполь тростинець
зло чином про ті люди насті з
надзвичайно гарний початок ми ядро ​​хіт
троянди для так з званого списку буча
гарантія того ж усі ви не будуть
притягнуті давид паві дальності ми моєму
повчать і
з'їм його ми повз почату роботу над усім
пакетом санкції акіма та ключ від
вказуємо орати на авто газовій парі
астана під ужну з брови про трасу та і
ніби ще ще ваші речі на російську
газ і нафту на пи дує на пробує і
демократії у Російській федерації і ви
спонсору і ти весь кову машину путіна ви
видача це кішкою на бомби на ракети яки
повертається ставок та громадян України
тварин крампа місце рахунок україні
будь-яка і компроміси з крим м рахунок
україни легалізували б його агресії щодо
суті сідлу бути днями винним квітам
боргу ще кордони держав можна змінити
цілу вона винний виберу незалежної нації
можна на квести в цьому
з у ряду десятки тисяч жертви і страшно
дням мільйонів українців міжнародно
правосуддя для ризикових за дуже сибур
ченський про список до якої включить з
всіх в інших співзвучний і
так звана мета довідкова назва
геноцидом проти українського народу
sweet травня прикро те ще поставить та
путіна та інших на перед міжнародним
трибуналом
мажу його
чоловікові його треба тут найвищому місці я знаю
цін
рогатий їм ширший ніж
віско води блокада українських морських
портив так допоможе в ряд уват з вигляд
путінського сценарію глобального введення
води
найсильніша фінансово-економічна
петренко україна сьогодні нам потрібно
фінансово допомогу я канікули раниш і
біржа братів книжка раді tiff
машалла 20 для вигляд буду ви україни на
основі стандарті vs так принципі в
спільної владності вид паве дальності
то розум області і я рада ще зайнятися тива
і
європейською і я рада ще зайнятися твоєю
np президент європейської ради шарлі
мішель чи то президент європейської комісії
урсула фон дер і plein
висунула ідея рахунку за основу
трастового фонду солідарності з Україною
а ще до українського майбутнього
каїнська нація
плата темно величезна ціна за нього ну
давайте неп примати автоматами в путіна
а україна
україна чека і на пузо ти поза рішенням
європейського союзу
ви видно застанемо про це не в Україні
на Україну не на оптимістичній шию націю
89 Адже сотні українців зроблю і
членство в ес і 70 сотки за
членство в нато і я у вічній зорі жартую
датчику пози всі nb рахунок utel харчування
хочу викликати своє по vue і поляку
астане овен імідж мажу його будванською
більше міжнародні води то бірж і
засміченості на Україні в
то ізоляції режиму путіна хотів би ви
солод і у вічності президент
європейського парламенту
знову реп цим від солі за її з ними ви
вирішили вид виду ти україна ванна бла ph
і представляється європейська народна
партія хто вид видів наш україна взаємно
простий годинник і до листа і частини нею на
воду я хотів би запити ти нового
президента н.п. тут немає і візит
так вже провести відпочинок з мого мандрівника
заходь до нашої України я буду під південним
символом і ми випадково відсікаємо вона вас
я буду рада цьому лічильні буди потужному
сином солідарності the pitt рамки нашого
народу дорогі друзі мій будні
європейського континенту за раз
виписуються в Україні і разом і моєму
трах би ти сама живий рахунок з роботи зі
для того ваще зуб in it агресія путіна
більше оружня більше санкцій бірж та
солідарності та жирних компроміс та розум
ми допоможемо і слава українам героям слава
морю край говорить про перше
[оплески]